Donald Trump held multiple rallies over
this final weekend before the 2022
midterms we already looked at rallies
which Barack Obama did let's now look at
Trump Donald Trump's rally was so
disastrous half the crowd started
leaving early uh reporters reported that
half of the crowd was walking out as
Donald Trump was still speaking one of
the new totally propagandistic things
that Trump has brought back is flying in
on his plane this is the plane his own
followers funded for him to get
repainted and to get back in the air and
you would think at some point these
people would go
you know I donated all that money to
Trump he didn't do a damn thing for me I
still have no savings I'm still in this
terrible situation here in Latrobe
Pennsylvania but he's flying in on a
brand new painted plane maybe I should
stop maybe it's time to stop overt
fascistic propaganda
shows up with the cheering cultists
but they don't think about it they just
go yeah this is the guy I'm supposed to
be voting for so let's get right into it
inside the cult inside the cult Donald
Trump did something interesting he
referred to Ron DeSantis as Ron Des
sanctimonious showing us he was going
public with the civil war between him
and DeSantis party for the nomination
like nobody's ever seen before
let's see there it is Trump at 71 Rhonda
sanctimonious at ten percent now people
didn't like this later when we look at
the Florida rally that Trump did Trump
didn't invite DeSantis
but he did say vote for Rubio vote for
DeSantis in the not even 24 hours
between the Pennsylvania rally and the
Florida rally people went to Trump and
said that was not a good look
narcissists don't like sharing the
spotlight Trump is furious that DeSantis
refuses to say I won't run against Trump
in 24. so he went with Rhonda
sanctimonious Republicans told him don't
do that that's not a good idea and Trump
backing off of it by the following rally
Donald Trump wrongly claimed that this
Pennsylvania Supreme Court ruled
that he won the 2020 election there take
a listen believe that basically said we
were all right
two weeks ago a week ago you're
you're or of Pennsylvania said they were
right the 2020 election with the respect
to the ballots and everything else the
2020 election was
not right it was not right it was not
allowed that is not what the
Pennsylvania Supreme Court ruled Trump
is lying overtly what the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court ruled about a week ago is
that undated ballots in the 2022 primary
were invalid 2022 primary undated
ballots they did not rule that things
were not right in 2020 and certainly not
that Donald Trump won Donald Trump
continuing to talk about 2020. and
you're all Democrat mostly I think just
about all Democrat that Supreme Court oh
sorry this is the this is part of the
clip we just looked at okay let's
continue Donald Trump talking about his
relationship with the Chinese president
XI
and Trump's saying I call him the king
now are you if necessary
when I went to China because I actually
until
the China virus came in I had a great
relationship with uh president XI is now
president for life I call him King he
says no no no I am not King I am
president I said no you're president for
life therefore you're the king as far as
I'm concerned yeah there are uh times in
American history
where for a president to say I basically
am calling this authoritarian strong man
the king
that would be a humiliating blunder for
for a president or former president to
say
and the crowd cheers now this is how
depraved
and debased
the right wing has become
Donald Trump then exploding in an
unintelligible word salad about the
media being the enemy of the people and
Russia it's unintelligent it's diarrhea
of the mouth folks communism this is
getting to be what they're doing with a
Catherine engelbrechten everybody
this is like a communist country and the
people we're not standing for a
communist country well there is no such
country here in the U.S so you don't
have to stand for it or sit we came
[Applause]
thing they do well is misinformation and
cheat on elections that's the only thing
and they're really good at that the
radical Democrats are locking up
pro-lice and you know this you see this
the pro-life activists they're being
locked up all over the place
they're persecuting their political
opponents I wonder who
nobody a friend of mine said A friend of
mine said there's never been a president
that's been treated like you after he
gets you know when you get out of office
you go and these guys come at you left
and right on such [ __ ] you've never
seen anything like that
another thing is that the crowds are so
childish that when Trump swears
the crowd cheers like that's cool I mean
it's it's it's quite literally like
eight-year-olds fine on their political
Rivals remember they spied in my
campaign and remember they did not spy
on Trump's campaign just as a reminder
just as a reminder
Trump's campaign in 2015 and 2016 was in
touch with so many suspected criminals
and spies that because those suspected
criminals and spies were being
surveilled
Trump's people were coincidentally
overheard because they were in touch
with those suspected criminals and spies
it's out of this world stuff and Trump
just says oh they spied on my campaign
they spied on my campaign Trump then
talks about documents the entire
document thing and he tells lies there
as well new Air Force One now Air Force
One is actually two planes it's two
seven forty seven eight hundreds by the
way nothing more relatable than when
Trump talks about planes and private
planes and they're quite quite the plane
I will tell you in fact I can't even
tell you what's on this plane because it
might be top secret and they'll try and
say oh he violated it document he
violated a document listen
everybody's accusing Trump of assault
now even the documents
it's violated every other president
takes their documents I'm the only one I
can't have a document but everyone else
they got them all over the place they
have them in Chinese restaurants and
bowling alleys you know that right now
remember that's also a lie what Trump is
referring to is there was one point at
which the National Archives actually
legally and officially rented a building
that previously housed a restaurant in
order to temporarily store documents the
archives had them the idea that George
H.W bush stuffed some documents in a
Chinese Laundry like in the in the dryer
it's completely absurd so then the crowd
starts leaving half the crowd reportedly
leaving while Trump was still speaking
they bring up Mehmet Oz Mehmet Oz says
tomorrow before the Steeler game
call 10 people and make sure they vote
the only problem the Steelers didn't
have a game yesterday but Oz who isn't
even really from Pennsylvania has no
clue what's going on
tomorrow morning when you awaken
I want you to contact 10 people do it a
church two before the Steelers game just
find the time and here's the question
you're going to ask them
are you happy with the way America is
going right there was no Steelers game
yesterday Sunday Oz knows so little
about Pennsylvania that he doesn't even
know when the Steelers play and of
course actual Steeler fans I assure you
know when the Steelers play the rally
was also in support of Doug mastriano
Doug mastriano took a different approach
which was during his brief uh moment in
the in the Limelight during the rally he
just groveled before Trump which is
really what Trump likes Pennsylvania Mr
President
Pennsylvania loves you
we need you
he was such a great president that even
Vladimir Putin behaved for four years I
mean Vladimir it's amazing it's
absolutely fantastic Pennsylvania three
days away from Victory we're gonna take
back our state recently yeah so
mastriano was on message he was just
praising Trump that's what you're
supposed to do and then lastly and this
was really weird Trump brought up
Christian televangelist lunatic Kenneth
Copeland and it got really weird
there are things
this great state of Pennsylvania
Liberty was born here
I've been accused of being a Christian
nationalist
our first president
1789.
this is not slowed down by the way this
Bible it's 17th chapter of Genesis
where God made Covenant with Abraham
and he read that
and he bowed his knee oh God and he
prayed
anyway
I won't play the full two minutes uh
Trump was completely bored during this
and very clearly regretted bringing up
Kenneth Copeland absolutely deranged
rally we were there our correspondent
Luke Beasley was on the ground in
Latrobe we'll have those clips after the
break remember
if you watch our content make sure
you're subscribed to the podcast on
whatever podcast platform you use it's
free and make sure you are subscribed on
YouTube I just got updated numbers from
October
3.2 million individual people
watched our clips
aren't subscribed on YouTube If just
those 3.2 million people subscribe we
would immediately be tied for the
biggest Progressive YouTube channel on
the internet
huge numbers of people report that CBD
has a calming effect that can help with
anxiety stress insomnia and our sponsor
feels is a premium CBD designed to help
you feel your best delivered right to
your door you just place a few drops of
feels under your tongue CBD can also be
a safe method for relieving minor aches
and pains without side effects the thing
to remember about CBD is that finding
the right dose is important and feels
even has experts on call to help you
with that over the phone if you need a
dose of Chill on the go you've got the
feels CBD infused mints and you'll get
fresh breath hard to complain about that
and with a feels monthly membership CBD
is simply a breeze you save money on
every order you can pause or cancel at
any time become a member today and get
50 off your first order with free
shipping when you go go to feels.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below